hello and welcome to the session on what
is tensorflow today we going to see what
is deep learning very briefly and then
we will talk about what are the various
libraries that are available for
developing deep learning applications
and then we will focus on tensorflow and
what are the various advantages why we
should use tensorflow what distance of
flow and then we will talk about what
are tensors which are as the name
suggests ends the flow consists of
tensors and then they are executed in a
certain graphical format of flow like a
graph and that's why it is named as such
tensor flow and we will see how to write
programs in tensor flow the programming
language of course will be Python but
there is a certain way in which you
write deep learning application or a
program intensive flow so we will take a
look at that this basic introductory
session for beginners and then we will
see one implementation of denser flow
code one full end-to-end and that's
pretty much it what you can expect from
this quickly wanted to mention that
there are certain prerequisites before
you actually go through this the
expectation is that you at least have
some idea about some programming
language and preferably Python if you
know Python absolutely it will be much
easier to understand the code as such
but even if you know any other
programming language I think it will be
okay and you will at least be able to
understand the Python code in addition
to that this also involves especially
the case study you will or the case
implementation you will be able to
understand only if you have some idea
about machine learning so in case you
are very new to machine learning and
write them everything then it may be a
good idea to check other tutorials that
we have uploaded on let's say about
Python and also about machine learning
so that you get a basic understanding
and then come back here otherwise it may
be very difficult to understand this
tutorial all right so having said that
let's get started so what is deep
learning again this video is not about
deep learning but there are other videos
we have created in detail about what is
deep learning in this video we'll just
touch upon the basics or that that's
nice segue into tens of long so deep
learning is in a way a subset of machine
learning and we use primarily neural
networks in deep learning and underlying
technology behind artificial
intelligence is deep learning and here
we teach them how to recognize let's say
images of boys and so on and so forth so
it is a learning mechanism but here
unlike traditional machine learning the
data is far more complicated and far
more unstructured like it could be
primarily in the form of images or audio
files or text files and one of the core
components of deep learning is neural
network and a neural network somewhat
looks like this there is something known
as an input layer and then there is an
output layer and in between there are a
bunch of hidden layers so typically it
would be at least one hidden layer and
anything more than one hidden layer is
known as a deep neural network so any
neural network with more than three
layers altogether right based known as a
deep neural network all right so what
are the functions of the various layers
let's take a quick look so the input
layer acts up the input so this could be
in the form of let's say if it is an
image it could be the pixel values of
the images so that's what the input
layer does and then it passes on to the
hidden layers and the hidden layers in
turn perform certain computations and
they have what is known as as a part of
the training they have these weights and
biases that they keep updating till the
training process is complete and each
neuron has multiple weights and there
will be one bias and these are like
variables and we will see when we go
into the tensor flow code what we
actually mean by that and so that's what
the hidden layer does it does a bunch of
computation and passes its values to the
output layer and then the output layer
in turn gives the output it could be in
the form of a class so for example if
you are doing classification it tells us
which class a particular image maybe
belongs to for example let's say if this
is a image classification and
application then the input could be a
bunch of images of maybe cats and dogs
and the output will be like it will say
okay if the
is activated this gives a zero and this
gives a one that means it is a cat if
this gives a one and this gives us zero
that means it is a dog so that is a kind
of a binary classification and that can
be extended with multiple neurons on the
output side to have many more classes
for example or it can also be used for
regression as well not necessarily only
classification again since this video is
not about deep learning or machine
learning on your network we will
probably not go into a lot of details
but you can check other videos where we
have given a lot more details about
neural networks and deep learning and so
on so in order to develop a deep
learning application how do you go about
primarily there are two or three
components that are required in order to
develop deep learning application you
need obviously a programming language so
typically Python is used and that's what
we are going to use in this particular
video but you can also use other
languages like Java or C++ and so on and
there are some libraries that are
readily available and for primarily for
doing machine learning and deep learning
programming so these are a list of
libraries these are by no means the
exhaustive list but some of the most
common ones like Cara's Theano
tensorflow and so on and so forth
tensorflow has nowadays become very very
popular this is developed by Google and
it is an open source library and Karos
was there before now carousel actually
now become a part of tensorflow as well
so it is one player about tensorflow
so in that sense they're well integrated
it's a combination of Keres and
tensorflow is pretty good then of course
you have a torch and DL for J and so on
and so forth so there are multiple
libraries but this video is about
tensorflow and we will be focusing on
tensorflow what are the benefits of
tensorflow and what are its components
and our towards the end we will show you
a code in Python we've written a code in
Python by the way tensorflow can be used
with multiple languages supports
multiple languages though Python is by
far the most popular language so let's
take a look at what exactly is
tensorflow and why we are so excited
about tensorflow
so tensorflow offers api's now we can
earlier without when these libraries
none of these libraries were there even
then we were doing people were doing
machine learning and deep learning and
so on but the coding mechanism was much
more complicated what these libraries
lectins of lower offer is they provide
kind of a high level API so that we
don't have to go really deep into
writing all the stuff that is required
let's say to prepare a neural network
and to even configure or even to program
a neuron and so on right so these are
done by the library so all you need to
do is they offer a higher level API you
need to use that API and call that API
and maybe pass the data and that would
pretty much it's much easier rather than
actually going down and writing
everything by yourself so tensorflow
that way it offers API is for to write
your code in Python or even C++ and so
on other languages Java as well it has
an integration with RS well apparently
okay and it supports CPUs as well as
GPIOs now deep learning applications are
very compute intensive especially the
training process needs a lot of
computation it takes very long as you
can imagine because the data size is
large and there are so many hydrater
processors there are so much of
mathematical calculations matrix
multiplication and so on and so forth so
for that if you perform these activities
on a normal CPU typically it would take
much longer
but GPUs are graphical processing units
you must have heard GPUs in the context
of games and so on because where you
need the screen needs to be of high
resolution and the images need to be a
high resolution and so on so GPUs there
as the name such as graphical processing
unit were originally designed for that
but since they are very good at handling
this kind of iterative calculations and
so on now they are kind of they're being
used or leveraged rather for doing or
developing deep learning applications
and tensorflow supports GPUs as well as
CPUs so I think that's one of the major
advantages of tensorflow as well now
again what is exactly tensorflow it's a
open source library developed by Google
and open source primarily for deep
learning development but tensorflow
also supports traditional machine
learning by the way so if you want to do
some traditional machine learning we can
do it however it is probably a bit of a
Oh
had to use tensorflow for doing creation
and machine learning and this is really
good for performing deep learning
activities and again if you want to get
into more details about what's the
difference between machine learning and
deep learning there is another video
about it you can probably take a look at
that video what else it is developed
originally for large numerical
computation so what similar even
tensorflow has developed and never
thought of it as keeping deep learning
in mind but ultimately it so happened
that it's really very good for deep
learning development and therefore
Google has open sourced it and dense
afloat as the name suggests the data is
in the form of what is known as tensors
these are like multi-dimensional arrays
and they are very handy in handling
large amounts of data and we will see
that as well as we move forward and then
of course the execution mechanism is in
the form of graphs so that makes it much
easier to execute this code in a
distributed manner across a cluster of
computers and and also using GPUs and so
on and so forth right so that's a quick
overview about what is tensor flow we
will see a little bit more detail the
two major components that is basically
the tensors and the graphs let's take a
look at what they are so what a tensor
tensor is as I mentioned earlier it is
like a multi-dimensional array in which
the data is stored now when we are doing
deep learning especially the training
process you will have large amounts of
data and the data is in typically in a
very complicated format and it really
helps when you are able to put this use
this or store it in a compact way and so
tensors actually offer a very nice and
compact way of storing the data or
handling the data during computation
this is not really for storing on your
hard disk or things like that but in
memory when you are doing the
computation tensors are very really very
handy in terms of keeping the data
compact because they are like
multi-dimensional arrays so the data is
stored in tensors and then it is fed
into the neural network and then you get
alright so there are some terms
associated with tensors let's get
ourselves familiarized one is the
dimension and another is the rank so
what is dimension typically dimension is
like
number of elements in a way so for
example this is a five by four dimension
answer and then you can have again the
multi dimensions right so you can this
can be like three by three by three so
that is the dimension and then you have
ranks so what are tensile ranks ranks
are basically traditionally we would
have thought of as dimensions that is
actually in this case it is called rank
so it becomes easier when we see
examples so the tensor rank is supposed
to be zero when there is only one
element we also call this as scalar so
just one element and this is not really
a vector it's just an element like 200
it's also known as a scalar so such a
tensor is supposed to be having a rank
of zero then you have let's say one
dimensional array this is a vector that
row of elements this has rank of one now
if you have traditionally what we call
as two dimensional like a matrix for
example then the rank is two and in this
case the rank is three and it can have
more ranks as well as I mentioned it is
like a multi-dimensional array so you
can have rank five six and so on okay so
those are the terminologies in terms of
float terms dimensions and ranks so this
is just to make sure that we are picking
the same language so whenever we talk
about the rank of a tensor you
understand what exactly is meant by that
now in addition to tensors in which the
data is actually stored all right so the
data is stored in the tensors and then
once you have the data there is a
computation that needs to be done now
the computation happens in the form of
graphs so what we typically in a tensor
flow program what we do is it's not like
traditional programming where you just
write a bunch of lines and then
everything gets executed in sequence
here we prepare graphs various nodes and
then these are executed in the form of a
session and they use the data from these
tensors now I know this is a slightly
new concept for a lot of you so it may
be a little difficult to probably
understand in the first cut but when we
look at the code when we go into the
tutorial the code walkthrough I think
that time it
become much clearer as well but to start
with just we need to keep in mind that
we have to first prepare a cutoff and
when you're preparing the graph no none
of the code is actually getting executed
you write the code to prepare the graph
and then you execute that graph so
that's the way by creating a session
that's the way tensorflow program works
so and each of these computation is
represented as what is known as a data
flow graph and we will also see that
whenever you start tensorflow when you
create an object tensor flow object
there will be what is known as the
default graph and then if required
I know probably in the beginning it may
not be required but in more advanced
programming you can actually have
multiple graphs instead of the default
graph you can create your own graph and
have multiple graphs and use it as well
but there is always whenever you create
a tensor flow object there will be a
default graph and this will be very
nicely illustrated in the example code
that we will take to explain this so
there it becomes much clearer than in
these slides so the graph gets executed
and it processes all the data that we
are feeding all the external data will
be fed in the form of what is known as
placeholders and then you have variables
and constants again this will also
become clear when we take a look at the
code and once you have the graph then
the execution can be enabled later of
regular CPUs or on GPUs and also in our
distributed more so that the processing
becomes much faster as I mentioned the
training of the models in deep learning
takes extremely long because of the
large amount of data and therefore using
tons of flow actually it makes it much
easier to write the code for GPUs or
CPUs and then execute it in a
distributed manner so this is how the
tensorflow program looks so there is you
need to build a computational graph
that's the first step and then you
execute that graph so the first step is
to write the code for preparing the
graph and then you create what is known
as a session and then the in that
session you ask the session to execute
this graph so this will again become
much clearer when we
look at the core now what are the
various elements of a tensorflow program
as I mentioned tensorflow program is
slightly different from regular
programming that we do so even if you're
familiar with Python this may still be
new for you the way you write a
tensorflow program is different from the
regular Python programming that you
would have done or even machine learning
program you would have written some
machine learning program using
scikit-learn or regular Python libraries
this is different from even that so let
us see what are the various elements so
first of all the way we handle data
inside of a program itself is a little
different from how we normally do in a
normal programming language a variable
is a variable in your program right so
you have anything that can keep changing
you just create as a variable or even
constants in fact are actually created
as variables but intensive flow the
storage in the program consists of three
types one is constants another is
variable and the third is a placeholder
so and they are there is a lot of
difference between these types and we
will see how they vary and how they are
used and so on so constants are like
variables which cannot be changed so for
example if you define a constant like
this this is how you define a constant
by the way the simplest format is like
this like for example B is equal to TF
dot constant and then you give a value
here a slightly more advanced version is
you also specify the type so you say D F
dot constant 2.0 tf2d 2 so the type is
of type float now in case of constants
you cannot during the computation you
cannot really change these values so for
example if you want to change the value
of B from 3 to 5 or any other number it
is not possible so that is the meaning
of constant alright so then we have
variables so variables we are all
familiar with what are variables
whenever you use programming we use
variables so this is pretty much the
same this is the way you define
variables D F dot variable now one thing
you need to note is this is the only
type in which we have V capital ok
constant has C a small C and placeholder
a small P but variable as capital v and
t f dot variable and then you give the
value and then you can specify what is
the type and
you can use the variable change the
variable at any point in time with a
different value and so on you can update
the variable and so on so we will see
all of this in the code I will
illustrate how available is defined and
how it can be changed whereas a constant
cannot be changed and so on and so forth
and then we have placeholders
placeholders are really a special type
and this may be something completely new
for many of us who have been doing
programming but intensive flow this is a
completely new concept so this is very
important to understand this
placeholders are like variables but only
thing is that they are used for feeding
the data from outside so typically when
you are performing some computations you
need to load data from a file or from an
image file or CSV file or whatever so
there is a provision with the special
kind of variables which can be fed in a
regular basis because the reason one of
the reasons for having this kind of
provision is that if you get the entire
input in one shot typically it may be
very difficult to handle the memory and
so on so I think that was the reason
they came up with this mechanism where
you can feed in patches and there is a
certain way of populating the
placeholder we call this free dick feed
underscore dick and this is a parameter
name by the way and you feed the
placeholders right that is the meaning
here so there is a certain way of
feeding the placeholders and we will
again see this in the example code as we
move forward okay so there are three
types one is the constant which cannot
be changed once you assign a value then
you have variables which are like normal
variables we are all familiar with and
then you have placeholders this is
primarily for feeding data from usually
from outside but of course you can also
for temporary testing purpose you can
feed within the program as well but
primarily the purpose of a placeholder
is to get data from outside so all right
so those were the constants variables
and placeholders that is how you handle
data within the flow program and then
you create a graph and once you create a
graph then you have what is known as a
session and then you create a session
object and you create a session and then
you run a particular computation or a
node or an operation and so typically
what you need to do is every variable
or a computation that you perform is
like an operation or a node within a
craft so initially the graph will be
what is known as the default craft the
moment you create a tensor flow object
or TF thus TF here you see this is the
tensor flow object and again in the code
when we go into the code it will become
much easier to understand so when you
create a tensor flow object there is
like a default graph which doesn't have
any operations no nodes or anything like
that so it's like a clean slate the
moment you assign variables or constants
or placeholders each of them is
intensive load terms it is known as an
operation again you need to get familiar
with these terms and they are not very
intuitive this is not really an
operation you're just creating a
constant or a variable but and this C is
equal to a into B would traditionally or
would intuitively be an operation you
here you're actually performing an
operation but in terms of float terms
each of these everything is an operation
so if you are creating a constant that
is an operation another constant or
variable that's an operation so you can
actually run each of these and they are
also known as referred to as nodes and
when you are in your session you will
actually run each of these you can
potentially run each of these nodes okay
so a typical example would look like
this so you have two constants created a
is equal to TF dot constant its value is
5 B is equal to this and then you say C
is equal to a into B and then you create
a session now remember all this you're
just creating the graph at this point no
execution has happened correct so only
at this point once you create a session
and then you say session access dot run
C is when actually this whole thing will
get executed all right so that is a
different way of programming compared to
our traditional way of writing program
so you need to get used to this new
format and when we look at the code as
we move forward in when we look in the
jupiter notebook it will become much
easier probably to understand this
rather than in the slide so these are
the slides showing the code but what we
can do is go straight into the lab
and take a look at the various examples
that are there and starting from the
very basic one how you create variables
and so these are some of the slides that
are showing so this is about how to
create variables how to create constants
and the variables or costs can also be
strings so this is like our first hello
world program and we will talk about
placeholders how to define a placeholder
and how to execute and populate the
placeholder values into placeholder we
will see these examples in the lab
actually I will run the code and we will
also perform a small computation of
adding and multiplying these variables
and we will in the end we will take up a
use case implementation using tensorflow
so let's first go and see those examples
and then come back and I'll explain this
use case and then we will execute the
use case in the lab so let's go and
check our lab okay so I'm in the Jupiter
notebook environment and this is one of
the development environments we can use
this is regular Python any time you do
python programming we use chipton not
per card there are another of course
there are other ways of using other
tools like pycharm and so on but for
this particular tutorial i'm comfortable
using Jupiter notebook so I will show
you in Jupiter notebook so this is the
very basic example to demonstrate how to
create our variables and constants and
placeholders and what is the difference
between them how they behave and so on
and as I mentioned the assumption here
is that you know at least some basic
Python programming or some programming
language so at least you understand the
code here and first two pieces of code
you will not need machine learning a
background but when we do the use case
or the case study there it is expected
that you know at least some basic
machine learning concepts so in case you
need to brush up the machine learning
part you may have to do that before you
go to the third one but here just at
least some idea of programming will be
sufficient so what are we doing here in
this particular line or in this
particular cell we are importing
tensorflow it is as I mentioned it is a
library so we are import
tensorflow and we are calling it TF so
this is this is just a name you can give
it any name but it is very common and
everywhere wherever tensorflow
programming is that it is always named
as TF but you can name anything actually
okay so this will import the tensor flow
into my session now this is the way to
create a variable so let's start by
creating a variable and this is the name
of my variable I am starting by giving a
name called zero and I say zero is equal
to TF dot variable and then I'm giving
the value of the variable here so this
is the very basic way and the simplest
way to create a variable we will see a
little later there are other formats as
well but the bare minimum way of
creating a variable is this so I'm
creating variable by the name zero and
as I mentioned you need to pay attention
to the capital V here in case of
variable it is a capital v uppercase
constant and placeholders are lowercase
now I'm creating a constant then the
constant I am naming it as one and the
way to create a constant is TF dot
constant and then you give the value of
the constant so the value of the
variable here is zero and the value of
constant here is one and again constant
you can also have additional parameters
like a name and so on
probably you must have seen in other
tutorials or in other places where the
code is written but the basic format
construct to create a constant is this
this is sufficient to create a constant
so I created one variable and one
constant now what else can we do again
here there is no real execution
happening we are just building a graph
we have not yet executed any tensorflow
code we are building a graph and I will
show you how the graph looks as well
first let us understand the constants
and variables and so on and then I will
show you how the graph is generated and
so on so what I want to do here is I
want to add 0 and 1 and put it into a
new variable called new value so what I
do here tensorflow
offers these methods like add assign
multiply or you have matrix
multiplication madman
and so on right so I will use one of
those methods which is TF dot add and
then pass these two as parameters so we
can add a variable and a constant there
are no restrictions on that so this is a
variable and this is a constant so if I
do this it will be okay I did know how
to execute this code so it is giving it
no okay so what it has done is new value
will be equal to TF dot add zero one so
then we have one variable and one
constant now let's say I want to change
the value of the variable because that
is possible right so we want to change
the value of the variable to something
some new value so we have in this case
new value has one because we added a 0
and a 1 so new value has one I want to
assign this to this originally what we
called as zero so I will call that as
update is equal to TF dot assign so
assign is basically changing the value
so that's what we are going to do here
now it has not complained we'll just say
fine right there are no issues now let
us try this something similar with this
one as well so 0 is a variable so we
were able to change the value and we
will in a little while we will see what
exactly those values are but before
doing that now let's say i will
uncomment this part and I want to do
something similar for my constant right
1 is a constant now I want to let's say
change the value of the constant and
make that also something different ok so
if I execute this piece of code it will
give an error now again the message may
not be very intuitive this doesn't say
that you cannot do this for a constant
it will just say tensor object has no
attribute assign know that sometimes may
be confusing especially when you're
starting but the meaning here is that
one is a constant and you're trying to
modify the constant so it will not allow
that's the reason it is complaining so
let's put that back in the comment and
ok so that is done so only variables you
can modify now what do you have to do
let's skip this piece of code I will
come back to this in a bit but let's say
we start by creating you remember I told
you we need to create a session
the way to create a session there are a
couple of ways of creating a session but
this is for beginners this is the
easiest way all you need to do is assign
a variable called SAS or you can give
any name and that is equal to TF dot
session that is the session method here
and you create a session object by the
name cess now what I'll do is I'll skip
this as well there is a purpose behind
that now let's go ahead and run this
piece of particular operation you
remember I mentioned that everything you
need to run so the rise of now the code
has not really got executed tensorflow
code has not got executed you only
created the craft so only when you run
through the session is when that
actually the program gets executed so
when you do this now you see observe
that it is giving an error okay the
reason behind that is remember we skip
these two lines of code for variables ok
this and then this now this is something
very very important to observe if you
have variables in your code what I mean
by that is let's say you are not using
variables but you have only constants
and placeholders then this will not
complain and you will not get this error
but in our case we also have variables
so whenever you have variables in that
case you need to do an initialization
and this is just a standard code there
is nothing that we need to add or modify
or anything like that this is a standard
piece of code you create this name of
course can be anything you can give us
any name but this global variables
initializer is what you need to call TF
Dot global variables initializer this
will kind of initialize all the
variables that you may be using and then
again remember this doesn't execute
anything right so all you are doing here
is you're creating an operation but in
order to run that operation you need to
also run this known as run init
underscore ops so this operation you
need to run after creating the session
all right
so we executed this now let us execute
this and now when I run this piece of
code it will run successfully okay I
hope you observe that so it is whenever
you use variables these two
lines of code one is the operation you
need to create an operation for saying
global variables initializer and then
you need to run before running anything
else you need to do a session dot run
this operation okay again only if you're
using variables of course you invariably
in all your programs you will use
variables you cannot just write a
program with constants and placeholders
so you can pretty much assume that this
has to be there in pretty much all the
programs now again why this has not been
taken care of in the library that's a
different question but you need to keep
in mind and always remember if you don't
do this for whatever reason if you're
forgotten you will get an error and the
error won't be intuitive so you need to
remember this that this could be because
of the variables okay good so we have
seen how to create a constant and we
have seen how to create a variable and
we have seen that you cannot modify or
update a constant and we have also seen
if you have variables that you need to
execute or have these two lines of code
to initialize the variables and then we
have seen that after creating a graph
how to run the graph in a session and I
will show you a little bit more in
detail how exactly the graph gets
created and how it gets executed but
this was the first very quick code on
creating variables and constants now we
will keep going and we will also show
you or I will show you the placeholders
but before that one more small piece of
code so this is how you write a for loop
okay so we are saying five times you run
this piece of code now like any Python
program this is nothing different so you
have a for loop and this is indented
that's the reason and therefore you say
session dot run update so this will run
five times and it will get printed
that's also update will run four five
times each time it will come and do this
particular operation that's all we are
asking the system to do so let me just
run that and show you let me yeah so it
will okay so it has done five times one
that's four it is basically adding if
you recall it starts from zero it adds 1
to 0 then 1 2 1 2 and so on so
nothing but it is generating five
numbers one two three four five that's
it okay so then you can also have your
constants as strings for example so you
can also work in a similar way you can
work with string so most of the
computation happens mainly on numerical
value so we normally had handle numbers
but there will be situations where you
may have to handle strings as well or
texts as well so this is an example of
text operation so you can similar to
numbers you just create strings or store
in constants instead of a number you say
hello is equal to TF dot constant and
then you assign the string that you want
it to be assigned and then the next one
is one more string which is for world
and then you say add these two so it is
nothing but concatenation of these two
words hallo and go word so we will do
that and remember this is only creation
of the graph right so in order to
actually execute this graph you need to
run the session now you need to keep in
mind we don't have to create the session
once again
because once you create a session till
you close the session it remains valid
okay so we have created the session here
now till you say just got close it will
remain for you so that's why we did not
create one more so we are just reusing
that session says dot run hello world so
in this hollow world what is the
operation that we are doing here the
operation is add these two concatenate
these two so if I run this it will print
hello world okay now that's string
operation now we will take a look at
placeholders so this is slightly more
complicated and something new even for
people who have been writing programs so
but I will just explain it to it with a
quick example first of all how do you
declare or create a placeholder you just
do TF dot placeholder in the P is lower
case only in case of variables the B is
upper case but otherwise passed in a
place holders it is lower case and you
just say because as I mentioned this is
a placeholder it doesn't have any value
so you
unlike constant or your variable you
can't usually you will not specify any
value you just say what type of
placeholder you want
very often most of the cases it is a
floating point so we just say
placeholder of type float 32 so the ste
F dot float 32 tells the system that it
is a floating point okay and then so let
me just run this and then you can do
some or define some computation like for
example B is equal to a into 2 now
remember here right now a has no value
but what we are saying here is at any
point later on when a gets some value
then B should be equal to twice the
value of a that's all we are saying here
okay and also as I mentioned earlier we
are not yet executing anything we are
just creating a graph view okay
so now you have that now how do you feed
the value or populate the placeholder
there is a certain syntax in which you
can populate the placeholder and you do
that using what is known as a dictionary
you are all probably familiar those
Python especially must be familiar with
dictionaries so you need to create a
dictionary and then pass that in order
to feed the placeholder so in this
particular example if I want to run
something if I want to calculate or
compute B obviously I need to feed the
value of a so the value of a I'm feeding
using this dictionary and I am saying
that a is equal to 3 now there are
multiple ways of populating the value of
a because it typically this won't be
just a single scalar value like in this
case right to remember scalar so it's
just one value one number typically it
would be a vector or answer very often
it is a tensor so we will see step by
step so we can start with a very basic
example where a can be a scalar so in
this case a is equal to 3 that's what we
are saying feed underscore dict
in this case feed underscored it is the
name of a variable by the way so you
can't give anything else here so if you
just say free it is equal to this it
will give you an error all right so keep
that in mind either you specify feed
underscore deck is equal to and give the
dictionary pause the dictionary or you
straight away like in this case this is
another format so let's see first let me
execute this it has given 6 ok I think
let me see if I can clear out this
particular cell so it becomes easier to
understand okay so it is giving you six
let me do that once again clear out this
and then okay and let me change the
format so this is one way of doing it
another way is you don't even have to
specify the name of this parameter feed
underscore deck you just pass the
dictionary and it will execute okay but
typically this makes the code readable
so that's the reason most of the places
whenever you find tensorflow code you
will see that they explicitly mention
feed underscore nick so that the code is
readable otherwise it can get confusing
so I will also come in this and retain
the other format okay so I hope it's
clear so what we are doing here we are
running the operation B and what exactly
is VB is twice a a into two so therefore
what we are doing and a has not been
doesn't have any value out here right so
that's why we are feeding the value of a
and then the operation gets completed so
a gets a value of three and then it gets
multiplied by two because that's what we
said here therefore B gets a value of
six and that's what is being fed into a
result and that's what is getting
printed here okay now as I mentioned it
need not be just a scalar value it can
be a vector with multi dimension array
and so on and so forth so let's start
showing you examples of that okay let me
just clear out the outputs let me clear
this okay you can also do before running
up this you could we could also do clear
all output all output clear it will
clear everything but that will will have
to start all over again so I am just
doing individually all right so in this
example we are taking one dimension
array where rank is equal to one and I'm
feeding three four five now let us see
what happens if I run this right as you
can imagine it gets multiplied each
number gets multiplied so the result is
six eight ten okay now as I said it can
get more complicated now let's say this
is a multi-dimensional vector so if you
what happens if you feed this okay
so as you can see this is pretty
complicated no but
if you feed this again all you're doing
is there is okay there is a slight
change here again you can also create
your dictionary outside and feed that
here you don't have to directly do it
here like in this case you see there are
variations of the exact syntax in the
way you write it right so there is a
slight variation so in this case you are
creating the dictionary straightaway
here kind of in line but here you
created the dictionary separately
because it's more complicated and then
you are passing that dictionary here so
I said dictionary is equal to a and then
I am saying this is what should be the
value of a and I'm feeding that and then
I'm using directly that dictionary here
okay so this is equivalent to putting
this code here right so if we execute
this what happens same so you get
because a was a let's say this is a
three by four by two right so that is
one yeah three by four by two right so
you see here this is a multi-dimensional
array so you feed that and the values
you see here is one two three
it became two four six four five six
became eight ten twelve seven eight nine
became 14 16 18 and so on and so forth
okay I hope now you got an idea about
placeholders and in real life what
happens is you typically won't create
these dictionaries manually and this is
a quick demo we did this you will
actually read the data into this
dictionary and then you feed that when
you are doing the computation okay so it
could be a CSV file or it could be a
image file so the input is basically
read and fed in it usually it is also
done in patches so you don't read the
entire thing because they can be large
amount of data so that is the idea
behind having these placeholders and the
way we feed these placeholders there is
a provision there's a deliberately there
has been made a provision for this kind
of getting data into the program in
chunks okay now in this particular
example we will close the session here
and then I will show you what is the
other way of creating a session right so
now if I close the session here now if I
try to do anything with the session it
will
give us an error so I will probably not
do that right now now there is another
way or on the format and this is a very
common way of using the session but I
didn't want to start off with this
because this could get a little
confusing the a simpler way was to
create session saying sess is equal to
TF dot session but typically you will do
it in what is known as a width block
this is a very common way of creating
session so once you have the graph you
would execute the graph in a session
using a width block and this is the
syntax so you say with the F dot session
assess all right and then you put all
your code here so what will happen is
you don't have to explicitly close the
session the moment this width block gets
completed the session gets closed okay
so let's just take a quick look at this
example now if we let me clear this cut
it out but be clear okay so this is the
hollow world example little bit earlier
we did that
so I'm doing a width T of dot session
ssome result is equal to says dot run
hollow plus world and then I say print
result okay so within this width block I
am doing all my computation and this
gets executed now let's say I try to run
remember I created a session here now if
I want to let's say do something like a
run says dot run a it is giving an error
because the session is no longer valid
right so you cannot either you have to
run this if you want to run this you
have to run this in this width block or
you shouldn't have closed the session
here right you remember this we said
session dot close so since we have
closed the session there is no active
session therefore it is giving an error
okay now there is a third way of
creating a session but for now I will
skip it because that is very very
specific to notebooks and and so on so
we will just avoid that you start with
for beginners I think the best way is to
start with creating a separate session
and then writing your code and then
closing your session now of course
remember if you don't do this part says
dot close you do not give any error or
anything like that
only thing is that it's a good
and your resources will get released
otherwise if you do multiple of these
programs they are running then your
resources will get blocked that's the
only thing and to start with this it is
simpler to do it this way so initially
when you are doing you start with this
but as you move forward as you become
familiar with tens of flow programming I
would recommend all of you to get into
this model most of the programming terms
of the programming is done like this
with D F dot session SS alright so that
was one book or one page of code that we
have done explaining about variables
constants and placeholders now let me
explain how the graph works in this
example we are going to see how the
graph is created how the graph gets
executed and so on ok now that we got a
understanding of constants and variables
and place orders ok so it will start as
usual by importing our library and as I
said whenever you create a TF or
tensorflow
object there will be what is known as a
default graph and you can get a handle
of that by saying get default graph so
let's do that and you can display the
operations remember every node in the
graph is considered as an operation
right so as of now as you can see we
have not done anything we have not
created a constant or variable or
nothing right so there was there is no
operation so by the way let's do one
thing let's start with all output clear
so that I don't have to again do
individually so I'll just run these two
lines of code ok no so yeah so we have
the default graph and as of now there
are no operations so there is a method
called get underscore operations which
will kind of display or show what are
the various operations that have been
performed on the graph so as I said to
start with there have no operations
being performed so when I try to display
it's empty there are no nothing is there
no operations ok now let's see what
happens when we slowly step by step
start writing or building the graph so
my first step may be to create a
constant okay remember in the previous
example I have shown you how to create a
constant in the most simple or the
simplest way which is like constant and
then the number right now a small
extension of that is you can actually
give a name to your constant now again
this need not be the same I can say a is
equal to name and XYZ I can give
anything here okay this is just for your
reference but here for simplicity
because there is a purpose why I am
using the same name as the name of the
variable and there are other reasons as
well why you would give a name again to
a constant or a variable this is again
useful when we are using what is known
as tensor board otherwise it doesn't
have much value this additional name
doesn't have much value in this our case
also we will be seeing the graph and
that's why I am using this but otherwise
this having originally a name usually
doesn't add much value alright so let's
create a constant I created a constant
now let us see what's going on in the
graph so I will just say operations is
equal to get operations and if you see
here now you remember here it was blank
now you see the first operation is
showing up and this a that's the reason
I put here so it is showing as a and it
says that okay you have performed an
operation and there is a constant you
have created a constant okay all right
so let's move on let's say we want to
create a second constant and this is B
so if I see what is order the operations
list of operations that have been
performed you see here there are two of
them so you have operation a which is a
constant then you have an operation B
another constant you recall we in the
term operation here is not very
intuitive right so we are just creating
constants or numbers of variables and it
is saying it's an operation but that's
that's a terminology intensive flow
everything is an operation here okay all
right so then what else let's say I want
to create a third operation and that is
basically adding which is this is a real
operation in normal sense as well so
let's say I'm creating C which is
adding a and B and the C value obviously
will be a plus B okay now if we want to
see what is in C and we say C you see
here it is not showing 30 it just says
it is a tensor and it is of type int 32
right because we have not executed the
graph we are still only building the
graph I hope this makes it easy to
understand okay so we are just building
the graph we have till we do remember we
till we do a session and run a
particular operation you're not actually
executing anything okay you're just
building the graph all right so now let
us see what are the operations we have
done a B and now C so you will see there
are three of them a B and C okay now
let's do one more operation which is D
and Here I am doing multiplication you
remember we did a TF dot and now I'll do
TF dot multiplied and I'm multiplying a
and B and I'm calling this operation as
D so a has I think N and B has 20 so D
will be actually 200 when we execute it
right now it is just a tensor and it is
off shape in 32 okay and once again we
can see what are the operations ABC T
and let's do one last operation here
which is e which is once again
multiplication of C and D now that C has
30 which is a plus B and D has 200 which
is a into B so now C into D will be 30
into 200 which is equal to 6000 but as
we have seen earlier that multiplication
will not happen right now so now you
have built a fairly simple but operation
graph its consists of ABCDE 1 2 3 4 5
operations
ok so you built a small it's not a very
complicated one but a simple graph now
you need to execute these operations so
what you need to do you need to create a
session ok so says dot t-- f is equal to
session and then you can run these
session print says dot run e now I am
missing something do I have to
initialize the variables that's a
question for you think and tell me
do I have to initialize the variables
then remember I ran one piece of code I
think you must have got the answer I
don't have to because I am just using
all constants here I have not used any
variable here right so I don't have to
write execute that piece of code to
initialize the variables so I can just
create a session and run any of the
operations that I want to run so in this
case I am running session e operation e
write this operation e now I can
actually run individually instead of
doing directly I could have run only a
or I could have run B and so on and so
forth but in this case I have run E
which in turn will do all the required
computations which is for example
assigning the value to a and B and C
doing the multiplication and so on all
those operations will be performed which
are required to do the computation of E
ok now there is a small piece of code
that you can use to find out what are
the various operations that are there in
this particular graph in this case of
course it was very easy very
straightforward I have created ABCDE
but in normal programming in real life
this can sometimes help to see how what
is there in your graph what kind of
operations are going on in your graph so
you can write this piece of code and it
may sometimes help debugging as well
okay all right so I finished my session
what do we have to do we need to close
the session right because I did not use
the width block so I need to close the
session as a good practice so I close
the session good so that's how the graph
works I hope it was helpful in
understanding how variables and
constants and placeholders are created
in the previous example we saw and how
exactly you create a graph and then you
actually execute that graph that's the
way tensorflow program works that's the
structure of heads of flow program ok so
now that we understood the structure of
tens of grow programming let's take an
example and a classification example I
take some real data from from outside
external data or CSV file and try to
solve a classification problem for that
let's first go back to the slides and
understand what is the problem statement
and then we will come back okay so what
is the case here we have some census
data and which has all these features or
variables like the age of a person what
class what class what is this education
what is this marital status gender and
so on and so forth so there are a bunch
of a bunch of features that are
available and we have to basically
classify or not classify we have to
build a model for classifying whether
the income of this person is above 50 K
or below 50 K okay so there is actually
a label data available we will then try
to build a model and then see what is
the accuracy so that this is a typical
machine learning problem actually but as
I said tensorflow can be used for doing
machine learning as well so we will as a
simple example we will take machine
learning so this is all the high-level
the code looks and in intensive flow
programming we also take a help of
regular Python libraries like for
example it could be numpy or it could be
scikit-learn or it could be pandas in
this case and because before you
actually develop or before you train
your model create your model you need to
prepare the data into a certain format
and sometimes if you are doing machine
learning activity you all are familiar
those familiar with machine learning
will know you need to split your data
into training and test data set so all
that can be done using the regular ngon
tensorflow libraries right so these are
like regular Python libraries pendant
and scikit-learn and so on so we use
that and then prepare the data and then
use tensorflow for performing either the
machine learning or deep learning
activity now so what is the advantage of
using tons of low-tide
main advantage is that tensorflow offers
high level api's right we talked about
so in this case we will be using I'll
explain what is in the slide but before
that I wanted to just show you what is
the API that we will be using so we will
be using the estimator API we will be
using the estimator API to create a
classifier what is known as a linear
classifier now in order to do that you
need to prepare the data and you need to
prepare the data into a certain
structure or format and the API itself
needs to be fed in a certain way so that
is exactly what we are doing before we
get into the regular tensorflow code
okay so these slides will quickly show
you what exactly is happening but I will
take you into Jupiter's notebook and run
that code and show you so here we are
importing the data data is the name of
the file is census underscore data dot
CSV it's a CSV file and then there is
income bracket is one of the columns
which basically is our target that is
what is used that is the label rather
but this doesn't have numeric value so
it has the income so we need to convert
that into binary values either 0 or 1 so
that's what we are doing here and then
we are splitting using scikit-learn we
are doing splitting of the data into
test and training right so this is a
standard scikit-learn people some of you
who are familiar with machine
traditional machine learning and you
have done machine learning in python
using scikit-learn will immediately
recognize this this is a SK learner's
scikit-learn
and there is a readily available method
to split the data into training and test
that's what we are doing here and then
you need to create what is known as
feature columns and input functions
before you can call the API estimator
API that's what we are doing here and
data and also there are different ways
of creating the future columns for
numeric values and for categorical
values or rather for continuous values
and categorical values okay so that's
what it's mean two types we are doing
here and we will see again in the code
as well and then you create your model
so this is basically model is equal to
TF dot estimator linear classifier and
then you're feeding the feature columns
and also subsequently you will call the
training by passing the input function
and you specify how many iterations to
be done for the training process and
again this is all typical machine
learning process so there is nothing
specific for tensorflow here and then
you evaluate your model because this is
classification a model so you can again
take help of the scikit-learn
to test the accuracy and get the reports
evaluation perform the evaluation and
get the report like this one right so
this is the classification report and
you will see what is the precision
recall f1 score and so on again this is
a standard machine learning process all
right so that's pretty much as far as
the code here is concerned once again
let me take you into our lab and we will
get started with this particular code
now let me clear out the outputs so that
you can now step by step you can see
that but so this is our data and we will
actually this is just display here the
code starts from here so before when we
start with our tensorflow part of it as
I mentioned we know it remember in the
previous examples the data was kind of
cooked up internally we created some
data and we were using it right the
constants variables and so on here is a
real life example so you are actually
getting data from outside so you know
before we get into tens of low this is
actually a regular Python code so it we
are using pandas for example to create
our data frame so we will import pandas
and then we will basically read our file
into a panda's data frame and this is
how the data looks right if you do a
head it will give you about six readings
or observations five or six observations
and then you can take a look at how your
data is looking so for example you have
age work education and so on and so
forth and you see here this last column
income underscore bracket it says
whether the income is greater than 50k
or less than 50k so this cannot be on
this cannot be fed into our model or so
that's the reason we need to convert
this this will not be understood right
so this needs to be converted saying
okay there may be less than 50 K is zero
and greater than 50 K is 1 so that
conversion needs to be done before we
feed it into our model so that's what we
are going to do as we move forward so
this is the code for doing that okay so
we take this and then we define a
function and then we run that function
so now we have wherever it is less than
50 K it will have 0 and greater than 50
K it will have 1 so we have now updated
the data then the next part is to split
our data into training and test data set
so how are we going to do that we again
we take the standard Python library
which is scikit-learn a scalar library
and we use an existing function there
which is trained test plate and what we
are doing here is basically splitting
the data into I'm sorry I need to
refresh this and then this ok sorry
about that so once I done this what is
what are we doing here again those are
familiar with scikit-learn will
immediately recognize I am splitting
this into test and train and saying test
size is 30% so 30% of the data should go
into test and training should have 70%
okay so that's all we are doing point
three indicates 30% so you can again
this can be individual references some
people do it like 5050 some people 2080
and in other case we are doing 70/30 so
training is 70 and test is 30 ok all
right so we have so far we've been doing
regular ngon tensorflow stuff so
preparing the data so that we can now
use for tensor flow and in terms of flow
what we are doing is we will be using
the API called estimator now estimator
in order to call estimator you need to
prepare what is known as feature columns
so feature columns have to be in a
certain
format basically it is nothing but the
columns we have to put them in a certain
format and then when we are calling the
the training we need to pass what is
known as an input function again a
certain way in which you need to pass
that function so that is what we need to
do before we create the model and run
the model for training so the next few
lines will be doing that quick look at
before we even get in once again into
the it ends a flow code so this is just
showing us what are the various columns
names of the columns of this data okay
so that is what is shown here and this
is more for when I was writing the code
I could copy/paste from here that's the
reason I this line of code is there
instead of typing in these values okay
good so now is where the actual
tensorflow action starts so I importance
of flow and now I will use this feature
column functionality to create my
feature columns and there is a certain
construct how you create the feature
columns again probably the details of
that is out of scope here but just that
you need to know that we need to create
feature columns and the way you create
feature columns for continuous values
and for categorical values is slightly
different and that's the reason you have
two different blocks okay so for
categorical values you need to use what
is known as TF dot feature column dot
categorical column with vocabulary list
and again within this again there are
two ways in which you can create for
categorical values one is a vocabulary
list where you know how many types are
there so for example gender column can
have only male and female so in such a
case there are let's say a finite number
of values for a given column then you
use column with vocabulary list okay so
and then you say what is the name of the
column and what are the possible values
so in this case male and female now
there will be situations where the the
values that this column can have okay
first of all it is a categorical column
that means it can have names or some non
numerical values but the number of
values is
unknown or undefined so for example
occupation
now occupation can have any value it can
be self-employed it can be software
professional bank teacher doctor so many
possibilities are there and we don't
know in the given data
how many occupations have been listed
right so that is where you use what is
known as categorical column with hash
bucket and you specify the hash bucket
size so what did what this says is there
can be a maximum of thousand such values
so typically you give a safe number
safely large number so that you don't
run out of these number of occupations
so I think thousand is a safe number I
don't think there will be more than
thousand mobs patients now given data so
that's the idea behind it but that's a
judgement call we need to take what
should be the size of this bucket size
right hash bucket size so these are two
different types for categorical values
for creating the feature column so we
will execute this for all the
categorical columns obviously you need
to know the type of the columns and that
is where if you see right at the
beginning this information was provided
what is the data type and you see here
the column name and what whether it is
continuous or categorical this
information is provided in the census
data wherever we pick the census data
from by the way this was picked from
online from a government website and we
stored locally so on that website it is
mentioned the details of this data we
mentioned and they have mentioned
whether each of these columns is
categorical or continuous so that
information we have to use and we have
to create feature columns using this
categorical method for the categorical
type of columns and then for numeric or
continuous values you just use what is
known as feature column dot numeric
column okay so these are all continuous
or numeric values like a age education
number capital gain capital loss ARS
perfect these are all numerical values
or continuous values right so you just
say TF dot feature underscore colum dot
numeric underscore column and then give
the name of the column so once you do
that I think
I have executed the previous one yeah
this one now so your feature columns are
ready and you need to basically create a
vector of all these columns and we call
that as feet underscore calls which is
which is like a short form for future
columns now as you have seen I mentioned
earlier also there are two things that
are needed one is the feature columns
and another is the input function so
feature columns to first create the
model and then to train the model you
need to create an input function so now
we have the feature columns ready next
is to create an input function and there
is a certain way in which you need to
this construct is pretty much very
common construct so we will use that so
the input function takes these x and y
values for training and tests you
remember these are extreme is the X
values of the training data set and y
train is the labels of the training data
set so that's what we are using here
explain why train and then we specify
what is the batch size batch size you
remember I mentioned this is what we'll
say how many records need to be read
each time right so typically in when we
are doing the training process we don't
get the entire data in one shot we do it
in batches so what size you specify here
number of epochs in this case we just
say none but number of epochs is again
probably the definition is not required
here but at a very high level how many
times the entire data has to be passed
through the model right so if you have
thousand records and you pass all the
thousand records three times for
training purpose then you call that as
three epochs right so there is a
difference between the batch size and
epochs so when let's say we have
thousand records and you're saying batch
size is hundred that means there will be
ten batches right so if you take 10
batches then that is one epoch gets
completed okay then you the training
obviously doesn't get completed in one
round okay so you need to pass this data
again maybe a second time or a third
time till you get the right accuracy
that is known as a
okay again if you need more details
about this you may have to go through
the machine learning tutorial and it
becomes much clearer okay so you have
your input function as well let's
execute that okay and now we are ready
to create the use the API right so what
will we do we will create the linear
classifier using TF dot estimator dot
linear classifier and this guy needs
feature columns right so that's why we
created we did all that so much of
manipulations to create this feature
columns so we have feature columns so we
passed that and we create our model
there may be a few warnings don't worry
about that so we will just ignore that
and now we use that model and we
actually what we did is we created an
instance of the model we have not really
done anything we just created a instance
of the model now we will create the node
for training so model dot train and this
needs the input function remember we
created the input function so we need to
pass the input function and then we say
this steps is now telling how many
iterations this training has to be run
so we are saying 5000 and this may be it
will probably take a little long so we
will okay but that's fine I think we
will leave it 5,000 sometimes if you
have probably a less powerful machine
you can cut it down to maybe thousand or
something like that but in this case I
have a fairly powerful system so I think
it shouldn't take much long couple of
minutes for it to get over okay so let
us go back yeah I think this is that you
see here the R gloss has disappeared
that means this computation has done yes
okay this is stuff right saving
checkpoint for five thousand that means
it is done so training is done so now
what we have to do we need to do the
evaluation so again this is a standard
machine learning method so methodology
rather so training as there has been
done with the training data set now you
need to evaluate using your test data
set so that's what we are doing here for
example you see here X underscore test
is your the test data
said remember we used scikit-learn to
split the data into training and test
data set so X underscore test and a
quick question why are we not using Y
underscore test here like we did in case
of training obviously we are expecting
the model to predict the values Y values
right so that's why we don't pass the y
values here all right so let's execute
this for doing the evaluation all right
and then we put them in a proper format
because the output doesn't come out in a
proper format so we put it in a list
format and then we can just check yeah
so this is done and we can check what is
the first element in this what is the
probabilities and so on so it's just a
quick way to see if the values are there
or not you can take any value here right
any element here all right now that the
testing is done what we need to do again
we will probably put them in some kind
of what this is more of a formatting
thing we will just run through quickly
and then we will use once again
scikit-learn for finding out the
accuracy and so on because scikit-learn
offers what is known as the
classification report functionality so
we will use that and find out how well
our model has performed so you see here
again people with machine learning
background will be immediately able to
recognize this so it gives us what is
the precision what is the recall and f1
score this is pretty much like you're
getting like almost 85% accuracy which
is pretty ok and there are other ways to
increase the accuracy for example you
can run the training for more iterations
that is one way get more data and so on
and so forth or user this is a linear
classifier we could you have used a
nonlinear classifier and so on so again
multiple ways of doing it to increase
the accuracy but the idea here was to
quickly show you a piece of tensorflow
code and that's what we have done here
all right so let's go back to our
presentation and
let's see so what are the key takeaways
from this session we saw what is at a
very high level what is deep learning
and what are the various libraries that
are available for writing deep learning
programs and then we focused on
tensorflow we saw what distance of flow
what are the elements of tensorflow how
to write a tensor flow program what are
the elements of a tensor flow program
what are the various types storage types
like variables and placeholders and
constants and what is the difference
between them and how to construct a
graph and execute a graph so we have
seen all of that and then in the end we
went through a case and executed a piece
of code for classification so with that
I hope this was helpful we come to the
end of this thank you very much for your
attention and if there are any comments
please put it in the comment section and
if you have any questions provide your
email id and we try our best to respond
to your queries or questions thank you
once again bye hi there if you like this
video subscribe to the simple learn
youtube channel and click here to watch
similar videos Dinard up and get
certified click here